o drive-in
e aí
e quando eu tinha 5 anos de idade me
perguntar porque que eu queria ser
quando crescesse minha resposta era
certa queria ser motorista de caminhão
de lixo eu acho que eu nunca conheci uma
outra criança com só então parecido com
o meu mas o fato era que quando era
criança eu achava que o motorista do
caminhão era quem levava para casa todo
dia que ele conectava ao longo do dia e
fazer coisas que ele quisesse então saiu
eu quero ser isso e aí eu acho que eu
nunca enxerguei o disco como um disco
para mim disse assim foi um mundo de
possibilidades sabe aquelas caçambas de
entulho que a gente encontra na rua
enfrente as obras então eu sempre levava
alguma coisa para casa era pilha que eu
colecionava pedaço de madeira para
brincar de marceneiro era alguma
tragédia que eu sempre levava até meu
programa de tv favorito tinha a ver com
isso era guerra do ferro-velho que
passava no discovery uma batalha maker
dentro de ferro velho me amarrava né eu
lembro de um natal que eu ganhei de
presente no meu tinha um carrinho de
rolimã e uma um par de luvas de lixeiro
quero para frear o carrinho o carrinho
nem lembro onde que que vai parar mas a
luva de lixeira eu guardei me amarrava
na luva
o e mal sabia eu que disse era um
problema na cara e quem diria um
problema de gente grande se a gente for
parar para pensar numa família de quatro
pessoas gente tá falando da geração de
duas toneladas por ano é muita coisa que
a gente produz uma cidade como o rio de
janeiro são 10 mil toneladas todos os
dias que a gente gera e que vão parar no
aterro sanitário master sentar 80 km de
distância da cidade e o aterro
basicamente é uma montanha de lixo a
gente vai só empilhando lá chega a
altura de 20 andares de um prédio de 20
andares e lá tem tudo de ruim para mim
ambiente né gente tem geração de chorume
a gente tem geração de metano que acaba
contaminando não só o solo os rios como
contribui para o aquecimento global e
não precisava ser assim se a gente fosse
parar para analisar o que que tem dentro
de uma cerejeira a gente ver que mais e
metade do que a gente joga fora é sobra
de comida caso que ele fruta verdura
legumes que a gente poderia aproveitar
através da compostagem todo esse
material a gente poderia estar
transformado em adubo
e num processo que a gente faz a
natureza há milhares milhares de anos né
basicamente a gente escolhe os
ingredientes corretos a gente mistura as
cascas de frutas com folhas secas
serragem coloca nas proporções corretas
e mostra bota justamente os
microrganismos que ficam no chão da
floresta que são os fungos e as
bactérias e até as minhocas para poder
em transformar esse material a gente
fala que é um jantar um enorme jantar
que dura entre 4 a 5 meses e depois a
gente tem uma dupla que é maravilhoso
para qualquer tipo de planta e quando eu
conheci a compostagem foi justamente
quando fazia faculdade eu fiz engenharia
ambiental na ufrj e pirei com a
compostagem eu conheci um projeto de
extensão que eu trabalhava e eu comecei
a separar em casa no meu baldinho e lixo
orgânico para levar de ônibus até o
fundão então basicamente nos separarmos
levar fundão para fazer pesquisa e aí um
amigo meu me deu de presente um livro do
professor caio da ingrata cara gostei
tanto do livro que eu disse 7 vezes me
livre e me ama rico mas sem fazer
compostagem todo dia a gente conversou
com a letal do trailer da faculdade de
bom dia do bandejão e aí eu comecei a
estagiar numa empresa de compostagem de
grande escala que trabalhar com 25
toneladas todo dia eu ia para lá falando
que era um paraíso da compostagem
aquelas montanhas de lixo orgânico adubo
e amarradão e aí nessa época até minha
namorada falou que escreveram nerd nem
conversar você é um chato tu só fala
disso vai dormir falando disso acorda
pão disse que levava ela para a
faculdade para fazer compostagem também
é e e aí eu comecei a me perguntar tinha
certeza que era isso que eu queria
trabalhar eu vou ficar se faz tanto
sentido porque que todo mundo não faça e
as principais desculpas que eu escutava
dos meus amigos é cara eu moro em
apartamento não rola de criar minhoca em
casa bactérias e eu vou começar a viver
dentro de casa que tava fluindo super
bem porque o baldinho meus pais meu
irmão só separava ali dentro e eu que
tinha um trabalho de levar e fazer
compostagem eu acho que o baldinho tem
tem oportunidade em mais casos negócio
que pode mudar a situação e foi daí que
surgiu o ciclo orgânico justamente com
esses amigos eu comecei a coletar de bi
e os baldinhos os amigos com resíduo
orgânico e comecei a devolver no final
do mesmo saco de 2 kg de adubo para cada
um saber o que que virou o lixo orgânico
deles é eu escrevi uma cartinha dizendo
quanto que eu tinha coletado as emissões
evitadas a quantidade de abreu produzido
e aí foi mais barato desses amigos foram
só multiplicando cada vez mais gente foi
fechando o círculo com a gente e aí teve
casos de tudo teve caso de casal que
dividiu o baldinho então namorado levar
para casa da namorada lixo orgânico
tinha caso de crente que não conseguia
viajar e levar meu baldinho junto que eu
não queria jogar fora tinha teve caso de
cliente nosso que ia na feira com
baldinho para encher o baldinho para
completar porque já não enxergava mais o
resíduo da feira como lixo né esse como
recurso é teve caso do zeca que é um dos
primeiros clientes nós que ele começou
ele fala que para ele é uma o este
fechar o ciclo é um ato político né quem
vê se ele tá protestando batendo panela
ele tava testando todo dia em
o time dele e fazendo ali o que ele
gostaria de ver na cidade a gente vê
como a cena dessa e a gente a gente se
pergunta assim cara quem diria que até
tanta gente postando foto na rede social
com a lixeira né em casa assim vai tá
transformação para gente
e ele foi isso em quatro anos foram a
gente sair de cinco famílias para mim
que em outras famílias foram mais de 900
toneladas coletadas a gente produzir o
adubo que daria para adubar 600 campos
de futebol é a gente evitou as emissões
lá do da ter sanitário equivalente a 700
carros ao longo de um ano e você
continua e aí minha mãe que começou a
falar lucas não é que tu vai realizar o
sonho de criança acho que de bicicleta
tu não vai não vai dar conta não e eu
realizei a
e aí
[Música]
e quando estava chegando perto foi não
tem que tirar a carteira de motorista
que eu vou dirigir meu caminhão todo dia
é a namorada virou esposa e ajudante de
caminhão
bom e o que a gente descobriu é que o
maior desafio que a gente tem essa
mudança não é a parte da compostagem
comportar compostagem a parte fácil do
processo desafio nós que a gente tem
realmente a mudar vida mudará costume é
criar uma nova cultura né e por isso eu
queria deixar o convite para gente rever
o que tem na nossa lixeira e começará
com postar a partir de hoje muito
obrigado
e aí
[Aplausos]
bom obrigado